foreign
[Music]
upcoming dates here in Little Rock
Arkansas and Nashville Tennessee and
then I got a Canada run I'm doing ver
and I'm doing Vermont Pittsburgh
Cleveland Detroit Michigan tickets at
crystalia.com
um appreciate you there and there's also
that new merch that's live up and going
it is uh you got the pockets stay deep
uh the beautiful pocket stick you've got
the beautiful Pockets the beautiful uh
shirts and uh the t-shirts high quality
t-shirts and also hoodies of pockets
stay deep with the diving board on the
pockets to let people know you've got
Deep Pockets
um also we've got beautiful grow or die
hoodies for sale right now Winter's
coming and fall is here among others
chrisley.com thank you so
um yes hello and welcome to with a new
episode of congratulations
[Music]
I got this
chlorophyll water what the hell is this
it doesn't taste like water at all that
much
um
ingredients purified Spring Water
natural flavors chlorophyll
lemon juice here we go organic lemon
juice that's what I that's what I taste
it's supposed to be good for you I don't
know I don't care it's just what I
picked up didn't know it's gonna taste
like that so it's gonna be regular water
um
so I got that and that's great
um I'm just kind of a chlorophyll
drinking kind of guy now chlorophyll is
in Plants I believe I have no idea but
it's okay
um I
I uh am chilling I like magic mind I
drink magic mind little little shots of
the things drink it
and I'm focused
and it's a beautiful thing magic mind so
get on that magic mind tip
um
your boy
forgot your boy
got new new glasses
so here's the deal I'm not wearing the
new glasses obviously because you don't
see glasses on me but
you know what happened
so here's the deal actually with
contacts and glasses I don't know if
you're a contact square or a glass is
wearer and and also
let's just go to I understand how great
Lasik is maybe I'll get Lasik one day
didn't get it yet because still a little
bit unsure about shooting lasers in my
eye
right sounds like something that
James Bond would be hooked up in a
village would be like so laser will be
hitting your eyes in one T minus 60
Seconds
did he leave
and then James Bond would get out of it
but anyway
um
I don't I don't know about Lasik maybe
I'll get Lasik now I'm gonna get a lot
of DMS and comments under this saying
like you really should have changed my
life I got it and I had it for 20 years
I don't know
just maybe I'll get it but that that
aside
contacts are better Vision than glasses
so I never liked wearing my glasses
because I don't want to see less as good
as I normally would see yeah dude so why
would I wear glasses now I was at the
doctor's office and I was like the
glasses are not good they're not cutting
it and he was like let's try to ramp up
your subscription prescription but then
I'm like won't that ramp up my my
contacts subscription and he's like yeah
so I was like so I don't want to do that
he's like let's just see so I did it
guess what dude he goes like this he
says
all right so
you need new a new prescription but
guess what they don't make them in
increments for contact lenses only
glasses so your glasses now will
technically be a better prescription
than your contacts
so now he's a glasses boy and he's like
do you want the transition lenses and I
go
let me see what it's like and they took
the UV rays and put it on the glasses
and now my son my glasses get darker in
the sunlight
[Music]
and they don't get dark enough and I
look a little bit like Iron Man because
you know when he tense his glasses and
[__] but then I'm like also I don't look
they don't look dark enough but then
when I'm looking out of them
they're not as dark as regular
sunglasses and I like that because
regular sunglasses are too dark
honestly regular sunglasses are way too
dark especially if your car's windows
are tinted with mine are dude obviously
mine are tinted my car windows are
tinted and you wear sunglasses you might
as well blind so blindfold yourself
while you're driving
um
but yeah so I got new glasses and I got
two pairs holy [__] dude call me two
glasses two glasses speaking of um
speaking of glasses
um
oh dude
I actually thought
I actually thought I was gonna lose my
mind this week and I don't even mean
in like a oh he he would get crazy for a
little bit I thought my brain was gonna
break okay
I go to get some tattoo work you know me
look it dude I'm drawn all over
right I'm drawing all the [__] over you
know what I'm saying I look like a
classmate just went to town on me while
I was sleeping and
I go to get tattooed
as I'm getting tattooed I take off my
chains dude now
I only take off my chains for two
reasons tattooing and [__] actually
you know what I'll be honest sometimes I
leave it on I leave it on with my wife
and I try to make it hit her face
because that's real sexy you know it's
not low enough that's the thing about
chains
when you're uh when you're doing it
if they swing too low it could be a
caution it could be caution it could be
hazardous right
what what's the [__] Papu song My
Chain Hang Low hit her in the face
whatever the [__] I don't know dude but
my point is I take my chains off for two
reasons okay my chains are off now and
I'm not either I'm not getting tattoos
or [__] but you know what I mean
sometimes when I'm podcasting I guess
but so I took my
um
I think that's ludicrous it Blake breaks
to glass tables my chain that's so oh
yeah dude who's the rapper that says my
chain breaks glass tables when I sit
down so don't invite him you know so um
anyway uh well this is all over the
place this episode so I go to take my
chains off get some tattoo work get up
to Lee to leave check out the tattoo
look at the chains and think can't
forget to bring those home leave without
the chains yes okay so all good I know
I'm about to leave for Charlotte the
next day and I was at the top two place
from like two to eight leave more than
halfway home I forget my chains call the
guy I need to get my chains back he says
I mean I'm just cleaning up drive back
now here's the deal dude this is great
driving back now I am 40 minutes out of
my way no 50 okay because I already
drove almost home and then back and my
wife's like well when are you gonna be
home in like 15 minutes and I'm like why
did I even say 15 minutes it's not going
to be 15 minutes I said 15 minutes
because I was being you know it's being
hopeful hopeful for lotteries hopeful
that number one it wouldn't make my wife
mad and number two that it would
actually be 15 minutes for some reason
like all of a sudden
I'm just gonna my car is gonna do like
what the old GI Joe planes did where the
wheels just go and take off like that
right
but there's still traffic and [__] so I
go back I get the chains but while I go
back and get the chains now here's the
thing about cars
let's let's there's a lot of moving
pieces in this it's like the movie Heat
but it all makes sense in the end now
you can do Apple play in cars yes
beautifully convenient now you can do
Apple playing cards but you don't have
to do Apple playing cards you can do you
can use the cars map to to ask where
you're going now
that seems great but then you're like
hmm two things I can use which one do I
use so you can pick one that you like
great I like the car map because it's in
the car and I want the Mercedes to do it
okay I got the Mercedes that does it I
want the Mercedes to do it all right my
phone's for my phone stuff texting and
when I'm in the car I best be using the
car Maps because I want the Mercedes car
to do it
okay I paid for the package so I go like
this hey Mercedes how can I help you it
says I say take me home boom on the car
Mercedes okay now I get pissed off that
now
I gotta go back to the two place to get
my chains okay
I type it in my phone and I'm like you
know what I'm gonna do I'm Gonna Leave
the directions home
on my car map
and I'm gonna use the Apple [__] four to
get back to the tattoo place I'll close
out of the Apple thing when I get to the
tattoo place and then I'll just drive
all the way home using the car Maps yeah
dude he's so smart dude he figured out
how to do it without typing into many
things and having to retype things in
and whatever bro but I'm like I got this
[__]
dude how smart am I I'm driving I'm like
how smart am I I'm thinking about this
[__] how [__] smart am I that's what
I'm thinking about and I'm not I'm dead
serious there's no music playing I don't
drive to music I drive to thinking about
damn I'm smart
I get back now as I'm going to the
tattoo place what happens
the car for some reason flips to Apple
play yes dude so now
so I'm driving away from the let that do
place you know why because I'm driving
home you know why because the car
switched to the Apple play [__] so now
I'm like wait a second way too late I
get pissed off and I say well why can't
I [__] switch back and forth why did
you switch back and forth for me
so now I'm 10 minutes more out of the
way than I go to the tattoo place and
I'm like [__] thank god dude great
get in the car I already said I was
going to be home a half an hour ago
and I'm like holy [__]
my wife's gonna think I'm cheating or
whatever
but I'm not I'm just going back to get
my chain right something needs to hit
her in the face when we're making love
sweetie dude it has to do with
lovemaking it's not going to hit you in
the face logistically it's not going to
make any sense if we're making love and
nothing's hitting you in the face so
logistically I have to go back
so I get the chains right
start driving back home what happens
dude I'm in the car map hell yeah dude
I'm in the car map going home all of a
sudden the car switches back to Apple
play and I start driving back to the
[__] tattoo place dude
now you know me you've been listening to
the podcast for years how mad am I do
now I'm out of my Boop
that was mad you can be your top
spoiling ding ding ding ding ding yes
blood mad blood red man you're right you
win
dude so I get home at 10.
but before that I start driving home and
I start getting upset
I start getting upset because I'm like
holy [__] dude
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm I William's
already in bed didn't get to see him
today basically
because I had to shoot lifeline and then
go work out oh no sorry I had to shoot
lifeline and then go get the tattoo and
I barely saw William and if Calvin goes
to bed I'm gonna be so upset I didn't
get to see either kid
and I'm leaving tomorrow so I'm not
gonna see them for [__] three days so
now oh dude oh oh dude yo you think I'm
regular and can deal with stuff can't
started crying
[Music]
yup dude I started getting I started
raining dude started crying called
Kristen said please can you please leave
him up and don't let him go to bed
because I need to see him because I'm
really spinning out of control oh [__]
yeah dude oh yeah dude then I started
getting really sad then I started
thinking how many times am I going to do
the road and be away from my family then
I started thinking dude did I even make
a mistake getting this tattoo in the
first place it probably doesn't look
good then I started thinking about how I
hope it doesn't look bad and then I
started thinking about maybe I'm ugly
and then I'm starting to think about I'm
ugly and then I start thinking about I
only get uglier as I get older and then
I start thinking oh dude life's not
worth lemon yeah
I swear to God and I'm flipping out dude
I had to pull over yeah
yes dude guess what I did then I logged
into a [__] Zoom meeting on addiction
and a guy started talking about how he
was molested by his family when he was
younger and I stopped crying for me and
started crying for him perspective my
baby
[Music]
dude
I'm upset because I can't see my kid for
a half an hour dude and this guy got
friggin straight up lested
I logged in I was like do what could
save me now a meeting got into a meeting
did it
I felt a little better dude
nah you know it's all about perspective
people say a lot about the things about
perspective you know they're like oh
come on dude there's I don't like that
would feel like there's starving people
in Africa and it's like yeah all right
that's okay but everybody's problem
isn't that bad if you look at somebody
else
who has a worse problem what about my
problems what about how they're
frustrating
what about how my mom told me I need a
different I need to walk differently
when I was 10. yeah that's not starving
but I still think of it all the time
ever like five times a year
I got shaped what
shape that's all good
you could be a victim or you can get
shaped
your boy got shaped
so now what so
so I go so so I cope with bet things
badly and I get tattoos and whatever
dude I hide and working out but it's
fine man
running dude running running running run
running running run running running
running that song sucks you know
um
bro I did this bit on stage and I think
I'm gonna do it on stage still but I'll
still tell it on my podcast because it
actually kills on stage but bro
this is [__] hilarious the most
Charlotte thing happened in the world
Charlotte I went to Charlotte North
Carolina
this bit maybe I shouldn't do this on my
podcast I'll do it on my podcast [__] it
who cares I did my whole Australian
thing on a podcast
and then I did it on Netflix
this is just literally I already did on
my podcast but
um
so I'm bored I'm in Charlotte it's too
hot it's 100 degrees and also humid it's
too hot dude hey we're the ball
constrictors because it's too hot there
better be ball constrictors hey where
are lions dude it's too hot because it's
the Sahara Desert why is it so hot in
North Carolina in Charlotte and then uh
make it make it cooler right so I'm like
I'm like I'm gonna get waters I'm gonna
get
some things I need to get lotion for my
tattoos
uh because they were itchy I'll pick up
some mints and some water whatever the
[__] right
go to Walgreens
and get some stuff the lady's like you
need a bag no I don't need a bag but I
say yeah for some reason she puts all
the stuff in the bag I take the bag I'm
gonna use the lotion
so I go to the trash can and I go to put
the lotion on and I take the lotion out
of the package and then throw the lotion
in the thing in the trash can and the
bags on the trash can and I see a dude
walking up to me like this dude he's
walking up to me like this
now for those of you just listening to
the podcast and not watching it he's
rubbing his tummy while he's walking
which means one thing he's a black guy
no other race rubs her tummy and walks
with their chin back except for black
guys and that's fine you might think
it's racist I don't care that's how it
is and you know it racist or not okay no
Asians do like this unless they say rice
right and no white dudes do like this
unless they say barbecue okay but black
dudes will just straight up rub their
tummies for no reason
it's like they're just like maybe I'm
hungry I haven't checked yet but in case
I'm rubbing my tummy in case it happens
and I realize it all right that's
actually funny
so
so I'm like oh he's approaching me
so how's this gonna go and then I hear
out of the man's mouth
I know you got some in that bag for me
and I go oh this is a robbery
in my head I think oh guard your grill
in my head I think oh
my last couple of breaths
here we go last couple of breaths here
in my head I go nice to meet you last
couple of breaths
how many can I got can I get in before I
expire
just ripping them out hey what you doing
bro
just trying to breathe the most last
rest I possibly can before I expire and
you and you robbed me and kill me
so he says I know you got something in
that bag for me and I'm like God damn it
I ignore I do my best my bit the best
thing I do is ignore people if you say
something once to me guess what I do I
ignore it I never listen to somebody
unless they say it twice ask my wife
clean up the dishes okay clean up the
dishes and then I do it actually
sometimes it takes five six times but
whatever dude
I ignore I'm good at ignoring
plus I don't want to talk to people
then the guy says
I know you got some in that bat I know
you got something nice in that bag for
me so now I'm like oh dude he's using
adjectives now I'm [__]
I know you got something nice in that
bag for me getting closer to me and I'm
like oh [__]
he's gonna rob me and he's gonna be
super disappointed the only thing that's
in there is mints water and some lotion
that's good for black guys but mints and
water who gives a [__]
so
I'm like my heart start
like it was 65 beats per minute now it's
probably
89 90 91.
you know I'm not too scared because I
could hold my own I just hope he doesn't
have a gun but it kind of already he
wasn't you know his hand wasn't tucked
into his Eddie Bowers or anything like
that so he's as he says this a woman
walks from around the corner out of my
view into my view from out of my view to
into my view with a she's a big fat
lady who happens to be black has a big
bag of Subway sandwiches and says [__]
y'all this month this my lunch and
dinner
and I realized oh he's talking to her
and I'm just racist
crazy bro
ah
I'm racist
then I put the lotion on my tattoo and
packed it up and walked away
I know you got something in that bag for
me dog
I never thought I was getting robbed so
badly
middle of the day outside of Walgreens
they've got a [__] bag with a W on it
it's not like Gucci or Prada I'm like
this guy's a really really small time
crook
um
sometimes I write something in my notes
I have no idea oh I remember what this
is
oh dude the plane ride
first of all
American Airlines dude what are you
doing
United I don't use anymore because of
how cats run it but American Airlines
dude it's going on
dude your planes suck
unless maybe you're going to Europe or
across the whole country but my God I
flew to Charlotte then I flew I flew
American Airlines from LAX to Charlotte
then Charlotte to Knoxville and then
Knoxville to Dallas and then Dallas to
La all the same plane dude here's the
deal American Airlines
they don't have TVs in the in the
airplane now first of all I'm just gonna
throw out a blanket statement on that no
have TVs on your [__] airplanes and
every on your airplanes in either a site
in every seat dude in every seat have
have I don't care we all have phones and
iPads and [__] have
you need to do that or else I'm gonna
dude I'll fly Spirit dude oh holy spirit
so
we're uh
I get on the plane and I'm like where's
the [__] TV and then I see a little
holder for my phone and it's like
it's it's like
the guy comes on first of all way too
loud yeah a Wi-Fi is uh available for
free uh for you to stream movies on our
website if you use your your tablet or
your smartphone you could use your
tablet or your smartphone and watch
movies and I'm like dude they want me to
use my [__] for watching movies
what about texting what about having fun
what about looking up at apps if I want
to watch a movie with Liam Neeson I
gotta watch it on my phone what else do
I do how am I supposed to watch a movie
without being on my phone right what is
this 1999
so I go all right well this sucks so
then I'm like I'm gonna guess I'm just
gonna get Wi-Fi I'm not gonna get even
though it's a five hour flight I'm not
gonna get I'm not gonna get what do you
call it
uh I'm not gonna watch movies
so I get the [__] uh
Wi-Fi
twenty dollars for an hour
twenty dollars for an hour now I know
Pockets stayed deep and get the
merchcrystalia.com and that's cool but
principal dude twenty dollars for an
hour
that's
one dollar every
three minutes right bro that's crazy I'm
so good at math
that's insane one dollar every every
three minutes
change it American Airlines change it
dude
I go to sit down in the thing and I'm
sitting next to this nice lady looks
like a really nice lady and she says
um
oh and I sit down
I know all I fly so much I know I know
what to do on planes you know I sit down
in the window aisle and I always get the
window not because I like the window I'd
actually might prefer the seat the aisle
seat except for one reason I want to be
able to control the window shades if I
sit next to somebody who want who
doesn't want to [__] close the window
shades and it's bright as all [__]
get out and I'm trying to like look at
my phone and I can't see it because of
the glare I'm I'm I want to start
punching
okay just around and hopefully I hit the
guy and um so I get to the window seat
the the shades are open and I I close
them I close them I close one there's
two shades for me okay there's the one
that's definitely mine and the one
that's a little bit in front of me that
is mine but if the lady reclines your
seat in front of me it's hers so I'm
like ah [__] okay
so I put that I put mine down all the
way I put that one down half the way all
right out of respect
I don't do it all the way yet the lady
next to me who's 55. says can I ask you
a silly question and I go
here we go in my head
here we go I got a talker right and this
is a five hour flight and I'm gonna sit
next to a talker
if if I I just parked my [__] on the
seat and this lady can I ask you
something question oh dude for five
hours she's gonna just be running her
mouth right so I'm like
sure hoping for the best and she says so
I know did she shut the blinds and I go
oh no dude
oh no this is gonna be an argument
she says I noticed she shot the blinds
and I say yeah and she says
how come you do that
and I wait for her to say more because
you know what I'm saying
because you know how you know why I do
it right
wanted to there are some things that you
don't have to ask
because you already know the answer
yes it could be anything like the answer
could be well because it gets hot or
it's too bright
right
so I said well what do you mean and she
says well like I know we get on planes
everyone seems to put the shades down
immediately why why do you why do why do
you think that everyone does that
and I said well I don't know why
everyone does it but
um I do it because I guess it's I don't
know I guess it's too bright and she
says huh so it's like a sensitivity
thing
and I'm like oh we're already done with
the con you know I mean like I mean
she's super sweet about it by the way
she says so you mean like it's a
sensitivity thing with your eyes and I
said uh I don't know I guess so yeah and
she says like it hurts
and I'm like dude how many levels does
this conversation with no levels have
you know
she says so it hurts your eyes
and I said I mean it doesn't really hurt
my eyes I guess but I just did it
because it's too bright and I want it to
be darker I think and she says yeah so
people do it just because of that and I
said yeah and I so badly wanted to ask
her
do you do it when you sit down or do you
not do it but then I was like I I can't
be asking her questions because then
this is a conversation right now it's
just a q a and it ends after I hey
but if I asked her cues after her cues
then we've got a combo going and I can't
have that especially minute one of a
five hour flight right
the [__] is this Larry King
so
so I say one last thing I said
I think you know what
there's an extra reason why I close the
windows
this window I closed because it was too
bright but the one in front of me I
closed to establish that it's mine
because it could be the person in front
of me
it could be the person in front of me
and she said oh so you did it to mark
your territory and I said yeah and she
said brilliant
word for word that was what happens
that's what happened and then
she didn't utter one other word for five
hours I couldn't
freaking believe it dude
God bless
thought about the whole flight thought
about it after we landed then still
thought about it on the way home
because I took another flight and I was
like remember that chick
hey people wear bad clothes in the
airport huh
like just straight up
bad bad bad bad clothes
I saw an Asian guy with dreadlocks at
the airport and I'm like dude did he get
those here because that's the worst
outfit for an Asian guy
How could an Asian guy have dreadlocks
hey guy
undread it and put gel in it like every
other Asian hey guy
on dreaded and just put too much Dippity
doing it like every Asian
the only people who use hair gel
are Asians and people in 1998.
you know
like you can't you can't bro gel oh my
God who are you Richard [__] grico
gel
people use gel you're Asian people use
gel also have a time machine gel come on
um so
I saw somebody with in the airport I
mean people just wear shirts in the
airport that say like who cares or
something you know
like just what
saw somebody in a
I'm over you know what I'm over
supporting anything
I'm done and it happened the other day
I don't want to I'm not into it no the
whole you know people support local
anything no uh-uh I'll get it wherever
how about that
support small business like yeah if
they're there you know but also I kill
you right
man they make horse [__] but still
um
so I uh
I saw a shirt that said this was the one
I couldn't this one just sent me
support
live
music
that's all the shirt said
what a [__] to imagine buying that
shirt seeing that and buying it like
dude there's no
other way to say I have terrible taste
in music than to just have buy a shirt
and say support live music because I
will tell you why
you don't need
to support live music because it's just
there's always gonna be live music
you know
keep that on the screen dude you don't
need to
you you need to
so
yo music
it's music
everyone
listens to music
everyone goes to concerts
dude when you have a concert to go to
people jizz their pants
people [__] on the way to the concert
because they're like I can't believe I'm
finally going to get to see these guys
and you that's like saying support sex
support breathing in and out
support jizen
dude support live music drove me nuts
people just want to say they support
[__] that's what it is I'm a good person
I'm gonna get a shirt that says support
support
dude people want to get people so badly
want to be a part of a cause dude that
they don't even know what the cause is
they're making up causes support live
music my ass dude don't I'm gonna get a
shirt that says Don't and follow that
lady around
that's so whack support live music that
kind of person is so boring you know
I don't support live music dude I
straight up don't I support getting
your Spotify going and getting your
Apple music going I support if you want
to listen to music go in your car and
listen to music best place to listen to
music in your car not at a live event
dude
whenever my friends text me they're
going to concerts I always text back
dude sit tight don't worry I'm Googling
where the exits are right now
dude I've seen some bad shirts have you
what are some bad shirts you've seen
drop a comment but let me tell you one
of the worst shirts I've ever seen I saw
a shirt on a woman that said give women
money
hooker
give women money
hey
on the back it should say cause I'm
hooking
give women money that's what's that like
the Equal Pay thing worst way of saying
it you know
the [__] equal pay thing is so stupid
for [__] sake dude when it comes to
sports at least
the ladies in soccer want to get paid
equally as like the World Cup World Cup
men biggest sport in the world world cup
women it's like it might as well be
badminton nobody gives a [__] you know
it makes 130 million dollars a year
globally and men soccer makes like 19
trillion dollars globally
and that makes like uh 6 billion or
something and then and then there are
women that are like we need to get paid
just as much as men and it's like okay
where's the money though dum dum
where's the money you actually make more
of a percentage women make more of a
percentage for the for for uh in soccer
than men do so actually you're right now
you should get paid less kicking a ball
around Sally I'll tell you what dude
you're kicking a ball around you know
I don't know man I just think if you're
a doctor you get paid the same amount I
don't care if your guy a guy guy or a
girl great you get paid the same amount
you get you know you're you're a lawyer
get paid the same amount you know if
you're good right
but like sports it's it there's there's
facts that back it up just there's
either money there or there's not
give women money
if I walked up and just gave that woman
100 she'd she'd be like well that's
disrespectful you know
one time I was at a diner and this woman
was looking at me this was so long ago
but she was looking at me she kept
looking and I I waved at her because she
kept looking and I was holding in my
hand what I was gonna pay for I had like
dollar the money in my hand and I was
waving it and then she had the nerve to
say did you just wave it wave money at
me
and I was like nah I just happened to be
in my hand [__]
oh dude I S I didn't see this but I I I
I saw this
and then didn't click on it
a whip meet up at a park dude so
dangerous at Crystal Lake Illinois
so [__] these people
oh
oh that's the dorkiest thing I've ever
seen in my life
dude just
um
you know under the breath they're going
like just a lot too
but they're not
dude so the one lady with the hand on
her hip oh the guys with two whips are
the best dude unbelievable
this video dude
this v a whip Meetup dude how do you
start a whip Meetup a forum hey guys
bring your whips we're gonna go to
Chrisley also
cops
get him
you can't have [__] whips around you
know
whip
meet up
this is unbelievable imagine being a guy
with a whip okay and it's not for sex
not kinky you know what I mean like a
cat of nine tails it's an Indiana Jones
type Whip and then imagine
she's a woman
a woman with a whip a man with a whip
bad a woman with a whip a orange
it'd be great if you're they were
panning you know because the video
they're like all right so here we go I'm
gonna take a video and put him on Tick
Tock I'm just gonna pan back and forth
so everybody wants you to do your best
whip moves so here we go and then as it
was filming you heard somebody in the
background my eye and they're like are
we gonna have to redo it Frank lost his
eye a little bit
we really got to show Crystal Lake
Illinois as the top whip area
just listen to it just listen to the
sounds
it's a [__] they're going to gray shirt
with the black shorts
wow
oh the guy in the back oh my dude the
guy the last guy that they pan across
has an Indiana Jones hat like dude how
could you get a whip period but then how
could you after that think yo it's
probably okay if I also get an Indiana
Jones hat guy you're sad guy
I'm crying for you
dude
like you know people are gonna be like
oh that guy wishes he was Indiana Jones
and I guess hopefully you don't care
about that but also
pick up checkers
dude whip Meetup is great
whip meet up
Eminem warns Vivek Rama Swami not to
perform or use his music anymore
it's great this is the politician who
um rap to Lose Yourself
so badly you know
um
Eminem's letter
who cares I think my name is pretty
liberal though
um
this letter serves as notice for you
pursuant to the BMI music
um
all right it's boring but that's what
it's also not Eminem's letter Pamela
somebody wrote it
but um it was sent to him not to do it
and I have the rap right here
um
in my because people send it to me
because I did Eminem impression and
they're like oh this guy's coming this
guy's coming for you
um
running out of breath
everyone's looking down
wow dude
so sad
but it is what it is and that's all we
can
give something
to kill the fly
Mel Gibson dude
Mel Gibson interview 1983. just getting
a bj start off by getting a bj by the
way put his hands up like that smoking
dude who smokes
kill the fly dick
for millions of fans Mad Max Israel
which are your yours
I mean get a different interview you
know four Millions
My Heroes my heroes
gee
geez everyone's got a hero
acting
my father oh cute
Mel Gibson's awesome an artist is he an
artist in a way yes he writes
um
so high you're right
flirting do you do you think that uh
actors have a
some responsibility I mean by the image
they give of humanity
yes responsibility to portray Humanity
right in a certain way in what way
I don't know but uh put it on if we if
you see a bad Max for instance yes true
this image of the 20th century ah and uh
I'm still running out of dialogue here
oh boy
what a funny question oh so mad dude
oh I I I do it I don't know how to
answer that oh dude sneakily giving him
the finger did this I don't know how to
answer that he did that dude that's
where that started
I don't I don't think I can I think it's
a silly question
time loving it dude
I think that's a silly question
I'm sorry no
did you find some cities by them uh
opportunity uh
impulse to become themselves you know
what dude if I'm having that interview
hey man this guy's too French
he's just too French right but of course
he's two French as we are all friends
but yeah I just get a guy who's a little
less French no offense we're in France I
get it I'm not French I need someone
who's just a little bit French and by a
little bit I mean a lot
famous to put himself on the first stage
of the first place
oh my God
no
I'm sorry I can't understand it
I'll find an impulse
Mel Gibson
and you you know already what you will
be you will be acting in the first time
the soon you have some projects oh God
wait hold on a second this interviewer
just isn't too French he's terrible you
know he's just so bad do you have other
projects what they say going on do you
like water
and you you know already what will be
you will be acting in the first time the
sooner you have some projects this guy's
having a stroke I'm working on a
a film now in fact I've had a few days
break I just came over from London and
it's uh
it's the story of the bounty and the
Mutiny
it's not a remake
it's a fresh look at it
thank you very much worse interview
uh
uh oh wow dude he was actually being
kind of nice you know because it's so
it's the reflex all right okay
oh my
God he was [__] good looking huh
Mel Gibson's the [__]
how
I wonder if he actually meant to give
the guy the finger now probably not
subconscious wow he's just so good that
he had no idea
he's so good he acts even
when he doesn't mean to bro let's check
this out
alligator 1980 official trailer
I actually almost watched this on um
prime or Hulu or shutter I can't
remember where I almost watched this but
I almost watched this alligator 1980
official trailer
it's like you know they made jaws and
they're like we gotta make this
eh 80s already
wow they'd never make it like this
it lives 50 feet beneath the streets bro
always in the 80s they would do that the
guy would come in like it was like
[__] that's the version of like an r
b when boyfriend would be like girl this
song would say like girl we've been
knowing each other for a long time we
just be friends but right now I want to
get horizontal with you
[Music]
dude is this movie on my [__]
dude I'm sorry
[Music]
50 feet
50 feet yeah
we can't be about my 36
36 long oh it is dude
it weighs over 2 000 pounds oh [__] they
know
and it's about to break out oh [__] dude
somebody's about my penis
yep that's how I scared dudes with it
and it was thick he said it was dark now
perhaps you're a mistaken that's it dude
my penis
everything about this movie could be my
penis
eyes would starve in a week there we go
that's about my dick dude
[Music]
she kept coming up with some garbage
about alligators in the sewers
alligators in the sewers
oh [__] that's awesome
there was no way to stop
playing you know
oh so get up dude
public is my job oh dude went to
Juilliard 100 went to Juilliard
the safety of the public is my job dude
went to Juilliard graduated top of his
class wow also tap dances like crazy it
could be anywhere there he is
so basic dude it could be anywhere
oh wow
I've seen what this animal can do you
better take all the help you can get
oh The Shadow
don't approach it dumb dumb
dude it hides in the trash wow the worst
outfit of all time
on my dick
dude honestly this is really good
special effects for 1980. what the [__]
dude it's huge
oh eating her puss
a gator
because Jaws was good
Robert Forster's in it that's amazing
I'm gonna watch that
dude I gotta put together some live
watches like TV stuff you know
um
reptile is a movie coming out with what
you've been feeling
um
Justin
Vander Beek what's his name Justin
Timberlake
dude every every trailer
dude how [__] dope is he could make a
woman come by sincerely by being in
front of the woman showing him showing
her his back
and having her lay down and
and he's just talking to her and then
makes her makes her [__] blast like
this he just goes like this
and she goes
oh and busts dude I swear to God he's
just talking like this about something
the sky you know the sky is absolutely
beautiful today I love how this guy
looks from 5 PM to 8pm depending on what
time of year it is and she's just like
oh my God
he's not even smoking he's just holding
his fingers like this and and exhaling
like he is
depending on what you eat you can have a
beautiful meal too you're sitting out
another Veranda somewhere
she's like oh my God and he's not even
looking at her and then he just goes
like this
and she goes
oh yeah
dude
and he's only wearing a blazer
so what happened
I walked out front door such a hard
music change I called out for her hello
[__] I'm gonna watch it so much
and then what
okay done I'm gonna watch it can't
dude movie trailers are so that one's
good so far I can't watch it here I
don't want to get all [__]
demonetized but
um movie trailers are so
bad dude
wait Breaking Bad two
no this can't be right
they're making a Breaking Bad too did
you know this
hi this is Brian Cranston the official
trailer for Breaking Bad two starts in
three two one can't be real
but it's honestly
everything that I did everything
flowed from that
from that partner no this is Faith
you did the kill uncle Hank oh hey still
alive
oh no I'm gonna avenge your death take
out that Neo-Nazi scum
I don't get it
hey Mariah is this a joke what is this
oh it's just
this is a joke but I don't understand
the joke
I wish this was real people are saying
who made this though and why is it on
oh she was right
only make prequels like I said
um
bro
remember [__] liver King It's just
sad at this point
in the modern world we like to have our
bowl of cereal don't we
this is a primal version
of your bowl of cereal I got my
testicles informative
why is a guy always eating testicles
I'm fresh milk from liver King Ranch the
most feared Warriors the Maasai
well they get down on is milk meat and
blood
and they're expressing a higher more
dominant form if you still want
your Primal cereal to tastes like cocoa
pebbles at the end
a little bit of whole feast in with your
testicles
make sure you peel back the membrane on
the testicle
oh my God
you can use a spoon if you want but God
gave you the hands for a reason
this guy's so gross dude I'm going to
town
oh
my god dude oh my God bro
oh my god dude like so gross why is he
just keep cutting off testicles
and eating them
bro he's got to be [__] four foot one
I mean man
people are like he's aged so much that's
because all he's doing is eating
testicles
bro this is the most disgusting thing
I've ever seen in my life
oh my
quite a few times 50 times more a
hundred times more
200 times more
500 times probably
you know
that [__] thing was the greatest meme
when it was when it was popping around
dude
you know
[__] man how many boners I used to get
on the road more 500 times probably
um all right that's good for now you
guys are great I really appreciate you
guys I'll be in Little Rock and
Nashville uh so leave a comment drop a
comment for that algorithm I gotta check
out that alligator movie you guys are
great if you're done if you want to
watch the rest of the episode this is
the YouTube version but if you want to
watch the rest uh it's uh Chris
patreon.com crystalia but like And
subscribe too my babies we love it thank
you very much and have a great day
[Music]
thank you